le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
au musée léon dierx jusqu'au 4 juin 2017
se tient l'exposition de manet à picasso
cette collaboration entre la
johannesburg art gallery et la
collection du musée léon dierx a permis
de rassembler des chefs-d'oeuvre
caractéristiques de l'art européen des
années 1860 aux années 1910 l'occasion
pour les réunionnais de profiter d'un
des plus prestigieux musées des outre
mer français
[Musique]
vous pourrez pas vous restez calmes et
vous avez tous le musée pour vous dans
un premier temps face au regard neuf de
ces petits visiteurs des oeuvres d'un
autre âge et des grands noms de la
peinture à saint denis
ces élèves de primaire s'apprête à
découvrir la nouvelle exposition du
musée léon dierx et pour leur expliquer
man et picasso ou renoir
il faut un traducteur va l'attendre
j'ai vu qu'il ya des couleurs
différentes du bleu et du gris et du
verre clé du verrou cia du mot il faut
adapter disent qu il faut trouver les
mots trouvés les des éléments qui qui
qui réveille leurs attentions qui permet
aussi donc de les solliciter donc d'être
de pouvoir les toucher plus facilement
elle est où la dame elle est assise mais
la droite à gauche devant derrière il
faut arriver après adapté à diffuser
puisque nos métiers on a toujours trois
points il ya un lieu une collection il
ya le public
si le public ne vient pas voir celui
aussi ses dieux sont toujours vides sans
public s'est pas amusé amusé c'est une
connexion entre un bâtiment ce qui à
l'inter de bâtiments et les gens qui
visitent ce bâtiment et c'est ça le ce
qui fait toute la force amusé la prit
d'abord une plaque brut comme ça pour le
musée départemental
cette collection d'oeuvres d'art
français allant de la seconde moitié du
19e
jusqu'au début du xxème doit profiter au
plus grand nombre
plus de 200 ch et d'oeuvres réalisées
par des artistes mondialement connus
nous sont présentées au musée léon dierx
et cela grâce à un partenariat qu'on a
su mettre en place avec la johannesburg
ap galerie qui est situé donc en afrique
du sud
c'est une opportunité pour nos enfants
pour nos familles de découvrir cette
grande richesse artistique que nous
exposons au musée léon dierx donc on
attend à un public
le plus nombreux possible une des
particularités de cette exposition
réside dans le nombre des stands parmi
les 200 oeuvres habituellement entreposé
avec soin dans la réserve
150 sont sur papier un support qui
implique des précautions bien
particulière le problème avec les
actions papier c'est que
il ya une contrainte il ya une
contrainte de l'exposition de temps
d'exposition à la lumière on ne peut pas
les exposer au delà d'une certaine
limite de deux mois là en l'occurrence
on va les exposés jusqu'au 4 juin 2017
après le 4 juin on va aller délai d
encadrer on va les remettre les
pochettes de conservation à l'intérieur
complètement à l'abri de la lumière et
on va les réintégrer dans les tiroirs
une période de cinq ans en sensibilisant
incident sur la fragilité des oeuvres
les médiateurs interpelle le public sur
l'importance de cette collection
ces deux oeuvres là ils sont arrivés en
donc l'année prochaine ça fait soixante
dix ans donc c'est de l'âge de vos
grands-parents pour certains d'entre eux
à ce n'est qu'en 2021
on pourra ressortir les deux dessins
nous le musée on expose là vous êtes en
train de visiter vous êtes contents vous
avez une explosion mais une de nos
missions aussi c'est qu'il faut qu'on
conserve avec 8ème dans l'exposition la
disposition des oeuvres ne doit rien au
hasard
la scénographie a été réfléchie afin de
faire vivre une histoire au contact des
différents tableaux fait beau pour une
exposition c'est un temps de fabrication
c'est pas une exposition ne se montrent
pas en quinze jours c'est impossible que
l'on est proche de la mise en scène d'un
théâtre je dirais qu'il faut aussi jouer
sur la mise en scène en solo
l'utilisation de certaines couleurs
phares sur la position des textes sur le
rassemblement des oeuvres entre elles
pour justement les mettre en valeur
et les offrir la vue du public
avec cette collaboration le musée
réaffirme son statut prestigieux dans
les outre-mer français je sais pas si il
faut sans cesse le dire mais en tout cas
il faut le réaffirmer à l'occasion de
cette exposition le musée landaise est
un des plus grands musées qui existe
dans les outre mer français le seul
musée beaux-arts de la réunion le seul
musée des beaux arts de cette qualité
dans les outre mer français et on a ici
des hommes majeurs qui pourraient très
bien figurer dans les grands musées
internationaux de renommée
internationale comme musée d'orsay
pattes
c'est un monsieur qui s'appelle philippe
leuba grâce à un partenariat privilégié
entre le musée et l'éducation nationale
plus de 3000 élèves vont profiter de
visites guidées et leurs professeurs
d'un dossier pédagogique qui fait le
lien entre l'exposition et les
programmes en histoire des arts
c'était bien
[Musique]
dire est qu'on a
on a rencontré des tableaux on n'a
jamais vu je suis bien aimé
les peintures flou
peinture m'a fait avec des crayons j'ai
retenu que ben vous pouvez pas qu'ils
allaient plusieurs manières de faire des
dessins et à la peinture il on découvre
des faisait plus belle
ces grands alors du coup bah on peut
revenir jour pendant que le bouche à
oreille fait son effet manet picasso et
renoir attendront patiemment les
prochains curieux jusqu'à la fin de
l'exposition
le 4 juin 2017
[Musique]
cette exposition de manet à picasso
unique dans cette région du monde a
nécessité plus de trois ans de
préparation et d'aménagement parmi les
200 oeuvres présentées au public
150 sont sur papier grâce à un
partenariat entre le musée et
l'éducation nationale plus de 3000
élèves vont profiter de visites guidées
avec pour objectif de conquérir un
public toujours plus large
le musée organisera sur réservation des
visites nocturnes de 18 heures à 19
heures à partir du mois de février
le public pourra également profiter
d'audio guides en français et en anglais
accessible sur smartphone grâce aux qr
code présent sur certains tableaux
la collection restera visible jusqu'au 4
juin 2017
pour plus de renseignements sur les
horaires du musée léon dierx où les
réservations
rendez vous sur le site du département
au www.cegedim.fr
[Musique]
m